the Supreme Court will hear arguments
this morning in two pivotal cases
challenging the consideration of a
student's race in college admissions the
cases involving Harvard and the
University of North Carolina could end
affirmative action as we know it at
public and private schools across this
country now the recent polling shows
that 74 percent of Americans oppose
affirmative action majorities across all
racial and ethnic groups say that race
should not be a factor when it comes to
getting into a college Jan Crawford
talked with students on both sides of
this debate Jan good morning I can't
wait to hear what people are saying
about this one this is going to be a
huge case Gail I mean obviously the
Supreme Court is gradually chipped away
at affirmative action over the years but
these cases could Outlaw the any
consideration of race in college
admissions even if the schools like the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill which we visited say it's crucial
for diversity
at the nation's oldest public university
a debate over the future of affirmative
action Jacob James is head of the
college Republicans at the University of
North Carolina everybody should get a
fair shot and affirmative action says
that no some people will be at Vantage
and other people will be disadvantaged
based on the color of their skin I think
it's more important now than ever Julia
Clark is president of the black student
movement I don't think there is ever a
time where we won't need affirmative
action or we won't need to talk about
race in every system that we have in
this country those arguments go to the
heart of the two cases challenging
affirmative action the court has scaled
back affirmative action over the years
outlawing quotas and numerical goals but
it has allowed a limited consideration
of race to promote diversity
but the newly conservative Court could
now decide that any consideration of
race at all is a legal discrimination
whether to private university like
Harvard or public one like UNC or
minority enrollment is already low
African Americans are about 22 percent
of the state population but only about 9
percent of the student body is black
civil rights lawyer Damon Hewitt is
representing the university when you
think about a world without affirmative
action think about what our workplaces
will look like what our schools would
look like America is stronger when we
actually fully embrace our diversity
many of us far surpassed the admission
requirements set by Harvard and other
colleges just for us to be rejected many
students who oppose affirmative action
like Calvin Yang support diversity Yang
is also backing the lawsuit against
Harvard where Asian students argue they
are held to much higher standards than
white or other minority applicants he
says schools should focus on giving more
opportunities to lower income students
if your economic disadvantage you should
get a boost rather than just arbitrarily
looking at the ethnicity the last thing
the skin color of a particular applicant
Yang a student at the University of
California at Berkeley was rejected by
Harvard despite top grades and test
scores but at Cal Berkeley admissions
officers are prohibited from considering
race California voters in 1996 banned
affirmative action in 2020 refused to
reinstate it eight other states also ban
it in college admissions the legal
effort to undo affirmative action has
been spearheaded by one man conservative
activist Ed Bloom he recruited students
to challenge the policies at UNC and
Harvard you can't remedy past
discrimination with new discrimination
for those who have suffered from
preferences for whites the remedy is not
preferences for African Americans or
Hispanics but for the students the issue
goes beyond diversity to the very
question of how they think about race
race was an important consideration in
somebody's character at the beginning of
the nation and it was wrong then and
it's wrong now but Clark says race will
always be a part of America I think
being colorblind assumes that we are all
the same and that we have the same
experiences and that we have the same
obstacles as well when we don't
now because there are different legal
questions for public and private
universities the court could reach
different outcomes another key
difference new Justice katanji Brown
Jackson will only participate in the UNC
case because she has recused from that
Harbor case as she served on one of its
boards Nate
Dan thank you so much our eyes will be
on this case that's for sure